[Música]
Olá, muito boa noite a todos. É um
grande prazer estar aqui com vocês.
Temos novos membros da nossa comunidade
fechada do YouTube.
Boa noite, Celso Moia. Boa noite, A1 FG.
Boa noite, Daniel Duarte,
boa noite Roberto Souza e boa noite
Regiane Gonçalve. Sejam muito bem-vindos
à nossa comunidade fechada.
É um prazer muito grande
estar com vocês aqui nessa live de hoje.
Muito bem, o assunto de hoje é a
cúrcuma, maravilhosa cúrcuma, na forma
de curcumina de alta absorção.
Boa noite, Márcio Luciano. Boa noite,
Flávio Ricardo. Boa noite, Claudinei.
Boa noite, Fernando Castediani,
sejam muito bem-vindos à nossa live.
Boa noite também, Flávio.
Bem, pessoal, vamos lá ao nosso assunto
de hoje. Depois eu cumprimento vocês
conforme vocês forem entrando, tá?
Eu vou contar uma história que aconteceu
aqui no consultório faz algumas semanas.
Tem um paciente de 54 anos, aquela cara
de quem trabalha que nem um condenado.
Bem, ele senta na cadeira na minha
frente e me diz assim, bem sem jeito,
doutor, eu tô tomando curcumina faz 3s
meses e não mudou absolutamente nada.
Gastei uma nota, meu joelho continua
inflamado, isso não serve para nada. Eu
acordo de manhã parecendo um robô
enferrujado. Aí eu pedi para ele me
mostrar o que que ele tava tomando.
Então ele puxou do bolso uma caixinha.
Eu olhei o rótulo e pensei: "Hum, meu
amigo, você literalmente
jogou dinheiro no lixo." Sabe por quê?
Porque ele tava tomando curcumina de
qualquer jeito. Vagabunda. Dessas que o
pessoal só raspa lá a cúrcuma, né? A o
açafrão, pega o pó e coloca na cápsula.
e tava tomando, sabe quanto? 50 mg por
cápsula.
Não tinha nenhuma tecnologia, não tinha
adição de pimenta preta, não tinha
orientação para tomar junto com gordura
saudável.
Era como se ele tivesse bebendo água com
corante amarelo, né? Efeito Zero.
Boa noite, Terezinha, Maria,
auxiliadora, Oni, Adilson, Egberto,
obrigado pela presença de vocês.
que realmente eu fico irritado às vezes
que as pessoas com maior boa intenção
procuram um produto de alta qualidade
e a gente tem essa situação aí de tá o
pessoal vendendo o gato por lebre na
internet ou até mesmo umas farmácias
menos éticas, o pessoal não está tendo a
devida
umbridade de tá explicando paraas
pessoas diferenças entre os produtos
diferentes, né?
Essa indústria também que não deixa nada
claro, empurra produto que não funciona
para cima de gente que tá sofrendo, que
tá com dor e que passa a não acreditar
mais no produto porque teve uma má
experiência. E esse pessoal precisa de
ajuda de verdade, né? A gente não pode
ficar aceitando que esse pessoal em dor,
uma inflamação importante que às vezes
tem um uma contraindicação de tomar o
antiinflamatório convencional, tem
problema de toma, problema nos rins,
problema de coração no fígado e a gente
quer oferecer uma coisa de qualidade,
uma coisa natural
e aí eles são passados para trás. Eu
fico realmente muito chateado com isso.
Então hoje eu vou te mostrar porque nove
em cada 10 pessoas que tomam curcumina
estão desperdiçando dinheiro. E mais
importante, eu vou ensinar exatamente
como usar cucumina do jeito certo, com
base em estudos recentes. São de 2024 e
25, então é coisa bem recente, tá? Boa
noite, Irma. Boa noite,
Gilberto Álvaro. Já falei. Obrigado pela
presença de vocês. Então, deixa eu
explicar uma coisa que vai mudar
completamente
a forma quando que você enxerga a
suplementação.
A gente vive numa época onde todo mundo
fala de cucumina, né? Tá bem famosa. É
um dos ativos aí mais estudados, tem
mais de 500 estudos.
Então você vai na academia, alguém tá
tomando, você encontra um vizinho,
uma tia,
né? Ela tá tomando,
alguém que tem artrose no joelho tá
tomando também. Só que a maioria das
pessoas não tem a menor ideia do que tá
fazendo, né? Olha que coisa
interessante. Tem mais de 15.000 estudos
científicos. Eu falei 500, mas esses 500
estudos são os mais conhecidos. Então
nós temos mais de 15.000 1000 estudos no
total sobre curcumina. Então ele é
praticamente um dos ativos mais
estudados junto com, né, ômega-3,
vitamina D. Então esse composto amarelo
que vem da cúrcuma, que é aquela raiz
que parece gengibre, mas é amarela, foi
muito muito estudado. Infelizmente nós
não temos aqueles estudos gigantescos
que são muito caros, né, os randomiz
control trials, mas a gente tem muitos
estudos. Então, os cientistas
comprovaram que a curcomina funciona
paraa inflamação, pra dor articular, pra
proteção cardiovascular, ajuda a regular
as gorduras do sangue pra função
cerebral e tem ação também anticâncer.
Então, a cucumina é um agente muita ação
simultânea.
Então, mas aí vem um problema que é o
elefante na sala que ninguém te conta,
né? Na cocomina comum tem apenas 1% de
biodisponibilidade.
1%. Tá? Deixa eu traduzir isso em
português claro. De cada 100 mg que você
engole, só 1 mg vai chegar na sua
corrente sanguínea. Os outros 99
passam direto pelo seu intestino, vão
embora. Às vezes isso até aceitável, às
vezes isso até desejável. Digamos que eu
tenho intestino irritável. Hoje mesmo
atendi uma criança com
intestino não irritável, mas tinha
inflamação intestinal do tipo
retocolitos sererativa.
Aí às vezes você quer que a cúrcuma, a
curcumina tenha assação local no
intestino, você não quer que seja tão
absorvida. Então, nesses casos, faz
sentido você usar uma cucuma assim, mas
pra grande maioria dos casos não. Você
quer que seja bem absorvido. Então,
quando só 1% dessa cucumina é absorvida,
é um grande problema, né? E os outros 99
vão passar direto pelo intestino. Podem
ter até ação local no intestino que é
interessante, mas o resto vai embora no
vaso sanitário. Aí você fica ali achando
que tá bafando, que tá se cuidando.
Então é tipo você comprar um carro, mas
só conseguir usar o retrovisor.
Tecnicamente você tem um carro, mas para
que que serve, né?
Um carro que você só consegue usar o
retrovisor.
Agora compara isso com remédio comum de
farmácia. Pega, por exemplo, o
Ibuprofeno.
Esse carinha, né, tem biodisponibilidade
de 80 a 90%. Seria um excelente remédio
se não estragasse o seu estômago, seus
rins e seu fígado, né? Então,
praticamente tudo que você toma do
ibuprofeno vai entrar pro sangue e vai
fazer efeito. De novo, se você tem uma
dor muito intensa, você bateu em algum
lugar, teve uma queda, teve uma
inflamação aguda, não há nenhum problema
de você tomar embuprofeno, de clofenáco,
nimesulíde ou secclofenacoo
durante até uns 5 a 7 dias. Não há
nenhum problema nisso, tá? Não é um
pecado. O problema é quando você tem que
tomar isso por muito tempo
e aí você vai ter os efeitos colaterais,
OK? Então aqui esse é o ponto principal
que a curcumina
não tem esses problemas, pelo contrário,
até protege o rim, ao contrário dos
antisantinflamatórios que vão gerar
problemas no rim.
Então a cucumina vagabunda, né, ao
contrário do buprofeno que 80% vai
absorver, ela não vai ser absorvida, vai
tudo pra lata do lixo.
Então é um desperdício de dinheiro, é
uma desesperança que a pessoa passa a
não acreditar no produto. Aí você me
pergunta: "Mas doutor, se cocomina não
absorve, por que que tem tanto estudo
mostrando que funciona?" E é uma ótima
pergunta. Essa é a questão que separa
quem tende de suplementação de quem só
repete o que ouviu no Instagram, no
Instagram. Então, os estudos que mostram
resultado de verdade, principalmente os
publicados recentemente, ano passado e
esse ano,
que foram publicados em revistas
científicas sérias, usam formulações
especiais. curcumina não é curcumina
pelada, são formulações com tecnologia
para aumentar a absorção.
E quando você aumenta a absorção, aí sim
ela pega, ela vai ser absorvida e vai
ter efeito. Aí você vai ver resultado.
Então tem um estudo de 2025 publicado
muito interessante.
Os pesquisadores compararam várias
formulações diferentes de curcumina e
viram uma coisa impressionante, certo?
Certas formulações que conseguem
aumentar a biodisponibilidade em 20
vezes, outras em 45 vezes e tem até umas
que chegam a 185
vezes mais absorção. Então você ouviu
direito, 185
vezes. Então é a diferença entre dirigir
um Fusca e pilotar um foguete, né? mesma
substância e efeito completamente
diferente.
Então, deixa eu te mostrar os três erros
fatais que a maioria das pessoas comete
quando compra a cucumina. Primeiro
erro que é o campeão, mais comum,
comprar curcumina comum achando que tá
fazendo a coisa certa. Primeiro que
muitas vezes nem é curcumina mesmo, é
cúrcuma ralada, como eu expliquei. Aí o
pessoal tem dificuldade de entender. É
fácil de entender, pessoal. Ó, veja bem,
café e cafeína, quando você vai comprar
no supermercado, você compra café.
Quando você vai na farmácia, você compra
uma cafeína. Muitas vezes você compra na
forma de pré-treino, né, para dar aquela
energia pro pré-treino. Então, ninguém
confunde cafeína com café. Concorda? Por
que você confundiria cúrcuma com
ccumina? Não confunda. Uma coisa, uma
coisa, outra coisa, outra coisa. Então,
cúrcuma é a planta de onde é extraída a
curcumina.
E aí você tem vários produtos no
mercado, vários tipos de suplemento,
alguns sem nenhum tipo de tecnologia de
melhorar absorção e nem concentrou ali
os cucuminoides. Os cucuminoides são uma
substância que a gente quer com o efeito
anti-inflamatório. OK? Então
não confunda. Lembra do café e da
cafeína? Você compra café na
supermercado e compra cafeína na
farmácia. É, seria a mesma coisa com a
cúrcuma. Você compra cúrcuma ou açafrão
da terra ou affronta da Índia
no supermercado e na farmácia você
compra cucumina.
Então, muitas vezes você faz o quê? Você
compra essa curcomina, entre aspas, que
é um açafrão ralado, achando que tá
fazendo a coisa certa. Você vai lá,
compra na internet ou v aquela caixinha
bonita, lê lá corumina 500 mg.
Pensa, nossa, que dose maravilhosa, né?
Vou tomar esse 500 mg duas vezes ao dia,
tá top. Vai paraa casa feliz da vida,
né, com a sua compra.
Só que você não perguntou a única coisa
que importa, as duas únicas coisas que
importa. Primeiro,
qual que é a padronização desse produto?
Ele tem quantos de cocuminoides?
E qual é a tecnologia de absorção? Se
não tem tecnologia nenhuma, você acabou
de comprar um pó amarelo caro.
OK? Segundo erro,
tomar sem combinação adequada. Muita
gente não sabe, mas a curcumina precisa
de gordura ou de pimenta preta bioperina
para ser absorvida, porque ela é
liposolúvel.
OK? Então, já falei isso em vários
vídeos no meu canal, quem quiser ver tem
acho que tem, deve ter uns 10 vídeos no
canal sobre curcumina. Então é tipo
vitamina D, precisa de gordura. Se você
tomar em jejum com estômago vazio, vai
diminuir muito a absorção. Pode
esquecer. Então já é naturalmente ruim a
absorção. Aí você toma um estômago
vazio, sem gordura, fica pior ainda. Ou
ainda nem coloca uma pimenta preta que
vai ajudar na absorção. E tem gente que
toma com suco de laranja pela manhã,
achando que tá bafando. Não tá, porque
não tem gordura junto, né? Não tem
bioperina da piperina, que é da pimenta
preta, tá jogando dinheiro fora de novo.
Próximo erro, dosagem homeopática.
Quando a gente trabalha com uma cúrcuma
ou curcomina que não é de uma tecnologia
de alta absorção,
50 mg, por exemplo, de cucumina não vai
fazer nenhum efeito. 100 mg também não
vai fazer nenhum efeito.
Para ter um efeito terapêutico de
verdade, para você de fato sentir
diferença na dor, na inflamação e também
melhora nos exames de sangue, você
precisa de dose adequada com formulação
adequada.
Não adianta tomar pouquinho de um
produto ruim, você vai continuar sem
resultado e vai sair por aí falando que
com serve para nada, não funciona. Ela
funciona. Você é que não foi informado
corretamente sobre o uso.
Agora vou te contar uma coisa que vai
mexer com você. Sabe por a medicina
ortodoxa, a medicina alopata não fala
quase nada de curcumina? Por que que o
médico comum, o médico que você vê aí
aparecendo nos programas muitas vezes
matinais da TV Globo ou horário do
almoço, por que que ele não comenta
muito sobre isso e por que que o médico
em geral não receita isso para você?
Então, deixa eu te dar um dado. A
indústria farmacêutica de
antiinflamatórios é uma das mais
lucrativas que existe e movimenta vários
bilhões de dólares por ano, né? Então
tem muita gente ganhando dinheiro.
Infelizmente também muitos desses
pacientes estão indo pra fila de
diálise, de hemodiálise. Lógico. De
novo, você usar uma semana, um
antiinflamatório, não vai acontecer isso
com você, a não ser que seja muito
azarado. Agora fica tomando aí
depofenáco, selecxib, buprofeno,
nimesulídia aí durante, sei lá, 4 anos,
vê o que vai acontecer com o seu rim.
Isso se você não tiver uma úlcera no
estômago antes, né? vê o que que vai
acontecer com o seu fígado,
né? Agora imagina se todo mundo de
repente descobrisse que existe uma
substância natural sem patente que faz
praticamente o mesmo efeito para uso
prolongado, né? Tô falando de uso
prolongado sem estragar o seu estômo, o
seu rim. O que que ia acontecer com esse
mercado multibilionário aí de
antiinflamatórios, né? Inclusive com
venda direta, sem receita.
E olha que interessante, tem estudos
comparando exatamente a cocumina com
anti-inflamatórios comuns. Então tem um
estudo de 2021 que revisou 15 ensaios
clínicos randomizados e controlados
talos RCTs, randomiz control trials,
certo? os dos RCTs.
E esse estudo então pegou a revisão
desses 15 ensaios, o mais alto nível,
né, de ciência por por serem RCTs, o
padrão ouro da ciência, comparando
curcumina com antiinflamatórios não
esteroidais
em pessoas com artrite de joelho. E sabe
qual que foi o resultado? A curcomina
funcionou tão bem quanto ibuprofeno e o
celecoxib
para reduzir a dor e melhorar a função
articular. Deixa eu repetir, tão bem
quanto e sem estragar os seus órgãos. E
pelo contrário, protege até o rim.
E tem uma diferença também gritante,
zero efeito colateral no estômago, nos
insígado.
Tem um outro estudo também
impressionante, foi publicado em 2019,
comparou curcumina com diclofenaco.
Diclofenaco, vocês conhecem, né, aquele
antiinflamatório que todo mundo já tomou
uma vez na vida, que o médico me receita
com muita frequência para inflamação.
Então, nesse estudo, 139
pacientes com osteoartrite foram
divididos em dois grupos. Um grupo tomou
cocumina, 500 mg, três vezes ao dia. O
outro grupo de clofenaco, 50 mg duas
vezes ao dia. Resultado, 94%
das pessoas do grupo curcumina tiveram
pelo menos 50% de melhora nos sintomas.
No grupo de clofenaco, 97%.
Então empatou praticamente a mesma
coisa, mas aqui vem o plot twist.
Significativamente menos pessoas do
grupo cucumina reportaram efeitos
adversos, ou seja, efeitos colaterais. É
o que eu tava falando agora. E nenhuma,
repito, nenhuma pessoa do grupo cucumina
precisou usar bloqueador de acidez. de
próton, né? Os famosos prazois,
homepraszol, pantopraszol, lanzopraszol,
esomepraszol.
Equanto isso, no grupo de culofenaco, um
monte de gente teve que tomar prazol
junto.
Você entende o que que significa isso?
Significa que a gente tem uma
alternativa natural, eficaz, comprovado
cientificamente,
que funciona tão bem quanto o remédio e
farmácia, mas sem ferrar os seus
estômagos, sem ferrar o seu coração, sem
aumentar o risco de infarto, sem
danificar o seu rim e nem danificar o
seu fígado no longo prazo. Mas o pessoal
da Big Farma não quer que você saiba
disso porque não tem patente, né? E
porque não interessa a eles. Qualquer
laboratório, né, pode trabalhar com
curcumina com com tanto que seja um
laboratório aí de
idôneo, né, que não vai te vender uma
porcaria.
Certo?
Agora atenção, porque aqui a coisa fica
técnica, tá? você um pouquinho técnico
aqui, mas eu vou explicar de um jeito
que você vai entender tranquilamente
como é que curcumina funciona no seu
corpo. Ela age em dois caminhos
principais. Primeiro, ela inibe uma
enzima chamada Cox2, CO2,
e ela é responsável por produzir
prostaglandinas inflamatórias. Que que é
prostaglandina inflamatória? são os
marcadores, são os mensageiros celulares
que vão levar a informação de uma célula
para outra de que tá acontecendo um
processo de dano no seu organismo, tá?
Então é exatamente o mesmo mecanismo dos
anti-inflamatórios convencionais, o
bloqueio das prostaglandinas
inflamatórias através da inibição da
enzima COC 2. A diferença é que a
cocomina faz isso de uma maneira
natural, modula a expressão genética
dessa enzima, enquanto anti-inflamatório
sintético bloqueia na porrada essa
situação.
Então, pode parecer a mesma coisa, mas a
abordagem funcional, aquela visão mais
ampla do organismo, mostra que regular a
expressão gênica é muito mais elegante e
seguro do que simplesmente bloquear na
força bruta uma via enzimática.
Segundo caminho, curina inibe o NFK
beta, tá? Esse é o maestro da orquestra
inflamatória. Então, quando você tem uma
inflamação crônica, esse carinha aí tá
lá ativado direto, mandando o seu corpo
produzir citocinas inflamatórias sem
parar. Então, a cucumina vai lá e acalma
isso daí. É como se ela fosse lá e
falasse pro maestro: "Cara, relaxa,
relaxa, não precisa tocar fortíssimo o
tempo todo, não". E tem mais, muito
mais. A curcomina, ela atravessa a
barreira hematoencefálica ou
hematolicórica.
E você sabe o que que isso significa?
Significa que para que ela consiga
chegar no seu cérebro, ela precisa
passar por essa barreira. Então, ela
consegue atravessar essa barreira. E a
maioria dos compostos não consegue fazer
isso. O seu cérebro, por natureza,
graças a Deus, é super protegido.
Tem uma barreira bem seletiva que não
deixa qualquer coisa entrar.
Mas graças a Deus também a curcumina
passa e lá no cérebro ela faz coisa
sensacional. fala protege os neurônios,
reduz a neuroinflamação,
aumenta um fator de crescimento
neuronal, um fator que ajuda os
neurônios se recuperarem é o fator
neurotrófico derivado do cérebro, é o
brain derived neurotropic factor, bdnf,
que é essencial para manter sua memória
e cognição em dia. Então, tem estudos
mostrando que a cucumina pode ajudar a
prevenir o Alzheimer e outras doenças
neurodegenerativas. A gente usa também
na prática clínica no protocolo recode
para tratamento do défic cognitivo.
Lógico, a gente não vai usar só
cocumina, a gente vai usar várias outras
coisas, mas ela faz parte do protocolo
recode de reversão do défic cognitivo.
Então, no fígado, a cucumina ela
potencializa a detoxificação da fase
dois. Ela aumenta a produção de
glutationa, ou seja, cucumina melhora
detox,
aumenta essa enzima fundamental, a gluta
que é um antioxidante mais poderoso que
o seu corpo produz.
Então, é literalmente como se você desse
um upgrade no sistema de limpeza do seu
organismo.
E no sistema do coração cardiovascular,
ela reduz a oxidação do LDL, como eu
tava falando, ela modula essa questão
das lipoproteínas.
Então, o que realmente nós queremos, que
faz sentido, não é dar porrada no LDL.
DD tem função do organismo. Ele pega o
colesterol, que é matériapra, ele leva
do fígado até os tecidos, ok?
Então
não é que o LDL é bandido, ele tem
função, tá? Então esse LDL é como se
fosse um navio que vai levando o
colesterol do fígado até os tecidos que
vão usar, principalmente a suprarrenal
que vai produzir os hormônios
esteroides, tá? Você vai precisar de
progesterona, vai precisar de cortisol,
vai precisar de endosterona, vai
precisar de testosterona, vai precisar
de de vários estradiol, estriol, tudo
isso vem da pregnenolona, que é
fabricado através do colesterol que vem
pelo LDL. O LDL não é bandido. O
problema do LDL é quando ele oxida
ou glica. E quando ele oxida, ele
atravessa a parede da artéria e inflama
dentro da parede da artéria. Aí a
artéria vai ficando grossa, vai ficando
calcificada até um belo que rompe o
ateroma e entope a artéria. Então nós
queremos o quê? LDL grande fofinho, que
parece uma bola de praia. Esse não oxida
e nós queremos evitar o LDL bolinha de
good, aquele duro e condensado, tá?
Então esse duro e condensado ele oxida.
Então a cucumina vai atuar reduzindo a
oxidação desse LDL, né? Que é esse o
processo que inicia toda a aterosclerose
que vai dar problema na artéria. Então
não é o LDL em geral, é o LDL oxidado,
que é o pequeno e denso que oxida.
da cucumina, ela protege contra sua
oxidação e além disso, ela melhora a
função do endotélio, que é essa parede
da artéria, aquela camadinha interna dos
seus vasos sanguíneos que precisa estar
funcionando bem pra pressão ficar
normal, circulação funcionar direito.
Bem, agora chegou a hora de falar do que
realmente importa. Biodisponibilidade.
Esse é o divisor de águas. Então, tem
basicamente quatro tecnologias
principais que realmente funcionam.
Pessoal, eu peço uma paciência para
vocês. A gente tá mais 10 minutos a
gente a gente termina essa parte aqui
teórica e eu vou responder as perguntas.
Façam perguntas relacionadas ao tema de
hoje, tá?
Então tem basicamente quatro tecnologias
principais que realmente funcionam para
biodisponibilidade, ou seja, que vai ter
disponibilidade do produto no seu
sangue, na sua corrente sanguínea.
Primeiro, piperina, que eu já comentei
agora aqui, é o composto ativo da
pimenta preta. Então, a piperina inibe
as enzimas que degradam curcumina no
fígado e no intestino. Então, com a
piperina você consegue aumentar a
absorção de curcumina em 20 vezes. 20
vezes, tá? Só que tem um porém aí.
Talvez seja aqui a pergunta da Maria de
Lourdes, tá? Vou aproveitar que tá na
minha cara aqui, ó. E impressionante é
que a médica gastroenterologista me
disse que a cocomina é prejudicial para
minha gastrite. Talvez ela tenha falado
isso, Maria de Lutes. Por quê?
Porque pessoas que têm intestino
sensível ou sim intestino irritável ou
gastrite,
a piperina que aumenta a absorção da
curcumina pode irritar o seu estômago.
Talvez seja isso que ela tenha falado,
tá? Tô já respondendo aqui porque tava
na minha cara.
Então, não é para todo mundo essa
combinação de piperina com corcina.
Então, qual é a segunda tecnologia que a
gente pode usar? Então, fosfolipídios,
que é a base da formação Meriva. Meriva,
além de ser um carro aqui no Brasil, é
uma marca de um produto muito bom nos
Estados Unidos. É uma é uma curcumina de
alta absorção, mas meriva não tem no
Brasil,
eh, a não ser que você importe. Então,
você pega a curcumina,
encapsula ela numa bolinha de
fosfolipídio, né, um tipo de gordura,
tipo uma gordura especial. Então isso
aumenta a absorção em aproximadamente 29
vezes e é bem mais gentil com o
intestino, tá? Então se você que tem
gastrite
intestino irritável é interessante
utilizar essa forma. Terceira forma de
você aumentar absorção nanopartículas.
Então já falei bioperina, né? A pimenta
preta, piperina, já falei do
fófolipídio, terceiro, nanopartículas.
Então você transforma curcumina em
partículas bem pequenininhas, em
partículas minúsculas,
tamanho nano, né, nanotecnologia.
E aí a absorção aumenta bastante. Então,
algumas formulações conseguem 185
vezes mais biodisponibilidade
para essa tecnologia aí. Quarta
tecnologia,
fitossomos,
que é parecido com fosfolipídios,
mas usa uma tecnologia específica que
liga a cucumina com fosfatiducolina,
que é extraída da soja,
de uma forma particular, que aumenta a
absorção em 45 vezes e permite que você
use doses menores com efeito potente.
Então essa tecnologia que eu vou
apresentar para vocês aqui como a
principal que eu gosto, porque você não
precisa tomar megados e também não vai
custar o olho da cara, porque a outra
tecnologia
eu acabei de falar do
aquela que eu falei que vocês que tem o
como se diz,
as microbolinhas,
essa daí ela é uma tecnologia puxada no
preço, tá? Essas nanopartículas aí.
Então essa é um meio do caminho, tá? Tem
uma absorção muito boa, mas não vai
custar o teu fígado, teu rim, tá?
Então você pode usar uma dose moderada
desses fitossomas com absorção excelente
que vai fazer um trabalho muito bem
feito. Então
quando eu escutei de um seguidor que
decidiu que queria ter
a melhor cucumina possível na loja de
suplementos,
então ela me perguntou: "Qual você
recomenda?" Eu falei: "Tem que ser
fitossomo, tá? Por quê? Porque você não
vai vender um produto com preço muito
elevado e também não pode ser uma
cocumina vagabunda, né? Então tem que
ser coisa séria. Então o produto que ela
escolheu para colocar na loja é o
CCUFlex.
É uma das marcas que eu vou apresentar
para vocês. Você tem toda a liberdade de
escolher entre várias marcas, mas o
CUFlex eu acho um produto muito
interessante. Não é o mais barato do
mercado, mas tá longe de ser o mais
caro, né? E é o que eu gosto de usar
pessoalmente, é o que eu recomendo para
boa parte dos meus pacientes quando eles
me perguntam qual marca deveria comprar.
Então vou apresentar aqui para vocês já
o produto. Esse aqui é o Corcoflex, tá
bom? Que é da Biobalance, marca bastante
idônea. Aí tem outras também, tá? Por
exemplo, tem a Curcomitec
da Nutrilibrium,
que tem essa tecnologia dos
fosfolipídeos Meriva.
Também um é um fabricante nacional do
mercado brasileiro
e tem cascos de 500 mg. Tem também o
curcomin fitos da Essential Nutrition,
também é um produto interessante que tem
a tecnologia Meriva
e tem também 500 mg por unidade. E tem a
cucumina long vida da Vitafor, que
também tem uma tecnologia de partículas
menores.
Beleza? Mas essa aqui, a Cocflex, é a
marca que eu mais recomendo.
Olha só que interessante, um estudo bem
recente de maio de 2025.
testou várias formulações diferentes de
cucumina em humanos, incluindo a
formulação copiperina
e formulação nova sol
que usa essa tecnologia micelar. Então o
que que eles descobriram?
Mesmo usando formulações ditas como de
alta biodisponibilidade,
os níveis plasmáticos de cucumina não
conjugada, que é a forma realmente
ativa, ficaram baixos. Então, a maioria
ficou abaixo de 2 nanomolar.
Então, a nova Sol conseguiu níveis
melhores entre 6 e 38 nanomolares nos
primeiros 30 minutos, depois caiu
rapidamente. Então, esses níveis ainda
são 100 vezes menores do que a
concentração usada em estudo de
laboratório para mostrar efeito
biológico. Então, o que que significa
isso? que talvez os efeitos benéficos da
cucumina não venham só da molécula
absorvida intacta, pode vir também dos
metabólitos dela, dos produtos de
degradação e principalmente do efeito
dela direto no intestino. Então, por
exemp porque a maior parte da cucumina
fica no intestino mesmo e não é
absorvida.
E lá ela faz um trabalho sensacional.
fala modula a microbiota, reduz
inflamação intestinal, protege a parede
do intestino. Então, mesmo com baixa
absorção sistêmica, ela tem um efeito
poderoso. Mas é óbvio que com formulação
de alta biodisponibilidade você consegue
somar os dois, o efeito local no
intestino e efeito sistêmico no corpo
todo. Agora eu vou dar um protocolo
prático, aquele que eu uso no
consultório com paciente de verdade.
Primeira coisa, você precisa de
curcumina com tecnologia de
biodisponibilidade.
Então, já falei isso várias vezes e vou
falar de novo. Curcumina comum não
adianta. Segundo, dose terapêutica
com fitossomo, que é o caso do curcoflex
que eu mostrei aqui. Deixa eu mostrar de
novo.
A dose eficaz fica entre 200 e 500 mg de
complexo por dia. Então, algumas pessoas
precisam mais, outras menos.
Então vai depender do grau de
inflamação. Terceiro, timing. Toma
sempre com refeição que tenha gordura,
almoço ou jantar. Se tomar café da manhã
gordo com ovo e abacate, né, que eu
recomendo gorduras saudáveis, obviamente
pode ser de manhã também, mas tem que
ter gordura junto. Quarto, duração.
Não adianta milagre em três dias.
Curcumina
paracetamol. Ela vai agir na causa da
inflamação, não só no sintoma. Então
você precisa de pelo menos 21 a 30 dias
para começar a ver resultado consistente
de 20 a 30 dias. Então, em alguns casos
mais crônicos, tipo artrite hematoide,
processo autoimune, pode levar de 60 a
90 dias para ter o efeito completo, mas
quando tem esse efeito é durador e
seguro. Quinto ponto, combinações
inteligentes. Combina vai bem com
ômega-3, que também é antiflamatório,
vai bem com bozuéia serrata, funciona
bem com vitamina D, que modula o sistema
imune, funciona bem com magnésio que
relaxa os músculos e reduz a dor. E
olha, interessante, tem situações que
você pode usar megados de supervisionado
de curcumina por tempo limitado. Por
exemplo,
pós-operatória de cirurgia ortopédica.
Tem estudos mostrando que usar dose alta
de cucumina nos primeiros 15 dias após a
cirurgia reduz drasticamente inflamação
e dor e acelera a recuperação. Outra
situação, exacerbação aguda de doença
autoimune. Você faz um pulso de alta
dose por 10 dias, depois volta paraa
dose de manutenção. Mas isso tem que ser
supervisionado, porque dose muito alta
pode interagir com alguns medicamentos.
Então, deixa eu dar alguns exemplos de
condições entre cucumina brilha.
Osteoartrite
comprovado em vários estudos, reduz a
dor, melhora a função articular tão bem
quanto o antiinflamatório.
Tritramatoide melhora marcadores
inflamatórios, reduz rigidez matinal,
diminui a demarticular e nacino
metabólica, melhora a resistência
insulínica, ou seja, baixa o açúcar do
sangue, reduz os triglicerídios,
aumenta então essa situação de saúde
das gorduras do sangue. Então, ajuda
também a controlar o açúcar do sangue.
Doença cardiovascular,
reduz a proteín serrativa, protege o da
oxidação, melhora a função endotelial
na esteatose hepática, ajuda a regenerar
o fígado gorduroso, melhora enzimas do
fígado, pode ser utilizado síndrome pós
COVID, reduz inflamação residual,
melhora a fadiga, acelera a recuperação
e no declí cognitivo, como eu comentei
anteriormente, pode proteger seus
neurônios, reduzir a neuroinflamação e
melhorar a memória. E que vai uma
inflamação valiosa que pouca a gente
sabe, cucumina potencializa a
quimioterapia. Então, tem estudos
mostrando que ela aumenta a
sensibilidade de células cancerígenas a
vários quimioterápos,
mas ao mesmo tempo protege as células
normais. Então, em protocolos
oncológicos integrativos, aquela visão
mais ampla do tratamento câncer, a
cucumina ela entra como advulgante. Mas
atenção, isso tem que ser feito com
acopamento médico, porque o timing
importa. Tem momentos que você usa junto
e tem momentos que você pausa antes da
químia. Agora, relação custo benefício.
Fazer uma conta de padeiro aqui. Um mês
de culofenác
duas vezes ao dia, sai uns R$ 20. É
baratinho. Só que você vai precisar de
omoprasol junto para proteger o
estômago. Mais R$ 20, R$ 40 por mês. Só
que no longo prazo você vai ter que
fazer idososcopia para ver se
desenvolveu gastrite ou úlcera. Mais R$
600, R$ 700.
Mais do que isso, na verdade esse número
tá até bem conservador e tem risco
aumentado de evento cardiovascular com
uso crônico de antiinflamatório não
esteroidal, que caso de culofenaco, tá?
Mas isso a gente nem vai colocar preço,
né? Porque a sua vida que tá em jogo.
Então o cucuflex tem tecnologia de
fitossomo,
custa mais caro, né? né? Não vou mentir,
mas você tá investindo em qualidade, em
absorção de verdade, em proteção ao
invés de agressão. Então, se você fizer
a conta total, você tá economizando. Na
verdade, não vai destruir o seu
estômago, não vai aumentar o risco de
infarto, não vai sobrecarregar rim em
fígado em investimento em saúde e não
gasto com remédio, né? É totalmente
diferente, né? Porque tá fazendo uma
coisa até de prevenção, prevenção de
alzimer, prevenção de câncer. Então é
bem diferente tomar o antiinflamatório
que é só para tirar dor. E aqui entre
nós, se você dividiu o custo por dia de
uso, não vai dar um cafezinho de
padaria. Então eu vou deixar o link do
curcuflex
na descrição do vídeo novamente. Você
pode comprar onde você quiser. Tô
simplesmente facilitando a tua vida. E
antes que algum chato venha encher a
paciência, pessoal, ninguém tá falando
aqui, você pode comprar onde você
quiser, tá? Tô facilitando a vida de
vocês. E eu consegui um cupom de
desconto com 10% de desconto para vocês
comprarem durante a live, tá? E até o
dia de amanhã. Então, quem tiver
acompanhando a live agora
e adquirir até amanhã de manhã cedo, vai
ter esse desconto
e você pode comprar qualquer marca de
qualquer site que você quiser, tá? Tem
1000 opções por aí. Eu só tô dando uma
orientação para vocês, porque as
perguntas, as pessoas estão sempre
perguntando qual que eu confio, qual que
eu recomendo. Tô aqui dando para vocês
essa informação, tá? E esse é um produto
que particularmente eu gosto de utilizar
e dou também paraa minha família e pros
pacientes, ok?
H, e outra coisa, pessoal, teste, não
fica só na teoria, pega seus exames
atuais, principalmente se você tem
marcadores aumentados de inflamação,
proteína ser reativa aumentada, VHS
aumentado, ferretina alta,
sem ser por excesso de ferro. Então,
pessoal, deixa eu só colocar o link aqui
para vocês. Eu vou lá no na página onde
tá correndo a live.
Deixa eu só tirar o som da
e eu vou colocar aqui na descrição do
vídeo.
Aliás,
ah, não dá para colocar aqui o link
ainda. Eu vou colocar aqui no bate-papo
embaixo
e depois eu coloco no no vídeo quando
tiver
publicado.
Então, tem um cupom de desconto. Deixa
eu pegar um desconto para vocês aqui.
Minuto só.
Deixa eu achar o cupom de desconto.
Eu vou colocar na tela.
Então, esse aqui é o cupom de desconto
e o link eu coloquei aqui, tá, nas
conversas aqui, mas eu vou colocar
depois também fixado no primeiro
comentário quando essa live acabar
para vocês clicarem, porque agora quando
a live tá rolando
não dá para colocar. Eu tenho que
esperar a live terminar para eu colocar
aqui o link
do primeiro comentário.
Bem, eu vou responder as perguntas, mas
antes de responder as perguntas, vamos
lá. Então faz o teste, pega os seus
exames atuais, principalmente se você
tem proteína ser reativa elevada, VHS
aumentado, ferritina alta sem ser por
excesso de ferro, toma essa cucumina
mais potente de verdade, biodisponível
por 60 dias certinho, depois repete os
exames, você vai ver a diferença nos
números. E mais importante que números,
você vai sentir diferença na dor, na
disposição, na qualidade do sono, no
bem-estar geral, porque inflamação
crônica afeta tudo no seu corpo. Então,
quando você reserve, quando você resolve
a inflamação, é como se desligasse um
alarme de incêndio que tava tocando no
fundo o tempo todo. Então, cucumina
funciona, mas tem que ser biodisponível,
tem que ser na dose certa, tem que ser
protocolo certo. Não adianta tomar
cucumina vagabunda e você merece coisa
melhor. O seu corpo merece coisa melhor.
Investe em qualidade porque isso faz
muito sentido. Você acaba economizando
longo prazo. Certo? Vamos responder
agora as perguntas.
Vou lá no começo do vídeo. Novamente
agradecendo os novos membros. Celso
A1 FG, Daniel Duarte,
Roberto Souza, Regane Gonçalves,
obrigado pela confiança no nosso
trabalho.
OK, OK, OK. Deixe seu like no vídeo, não
esquece de se inscrever no canal, deixe
seu comentário no vídeo, depois que
tiver publicado o vídeo também, a live,
você deixe seu comentário, por favor.
Boa noite, Oni Adilson, dei boa noite
para esse pessoal.
Ah, doutor falou aqui, doutor falou
sobre os colaterais, tá? Tá, tal. Qual
seria a estratégia para não tomar?
Eu não entendi bem essa pergunta,
gente. Vamos ficar no tema de hoje da
cucumina.
Boa noite, querido. Obrigado pelo pela
saudação.
Cúrcuma natural fermentada com pimenta
preta é boa?
É boa. Não vai ter a mesma absorção do
fitossomo. Vai, mas é boa, tá?
Ã, não tô achei, não achei o segundo
vídeo. Entra no meu canal, tá? É que o
pessoal geralmente faz busca no YouTube
direto, assim geral, né? Mas você pode
fazer a busca geral, colocar o meu nome
mais nervo vago ou é melhor ainda você
entra no meu canal e eu uso aquela outra
lupa menorzinha que tem embaixo e faz a
a busca, tá?
Olha, açafrão para uso por longos
períodos de tempo, né? Como os indianos
fazem, né? Eles indianos tomam a vida
inteira, né? O curry e outros temperos
lá que vai ao açafrão. Sim, ele tem um
efeito protetor a longo prazo, mas tem
que tomar durante muitos anos, tá?
De nada,
eh, motor é um produto bom, sim, mas eu
acredito que ele não é tão bom quanto o
cuflex, tá? Mas mas é um produto que não
tem uma tecnologia muito boa de
absorção, não.
OK.
Obrigado, Juvão. Abraço, um beijo para
você.
Tá vendo aí o Nel falando, não sei se é
ela ou ele, né, mas que ajuda muito na
inflamação da artrite.
Frida, escrever em inglês aí. Acho que
talvez
pessoa mora fora no Brasil, tá
acostumado com inglês.
Idosos com petenção material podem
tomar? Podem, podem sim.
Futuramente o doutor poderia fazer uma
live falando dos tipos de magnésio. Eu
já tenho vários vídeos falando disso,
tá? Mas a gente pode fazer uma live, mas
procura no canal.
Minha mãe tomou remédio que é composto
por ácido hialurônico, colágeno, tipo
dois e manganês. Ajuda também. Ácido
hialurônico é muito bom pra junta, né? O
colágeno também.
Ã,
boa noite,
a longa. Que que quer dizer isso? Não
entendi. Marcelo Pimentel, seja muito
bem-vindo ao grupo, tá, de apoiadores.
Muito obrigado, Jan, pela gentileza.
Boa noite.
Estou tomando 5 g de glutamina, 5 g de
cúrcuma com piperina e um comprimido de
cucumina 95%. Estou com pangrastrite,
você acha exagero?
5 g de cúrcuma. É isso mesmo. A dose bem
alta, né? Ela deve ser o tempero, né?
Você tá falando do tempero, né?
E um comprimento de curcumina 95%. Não,
não é exagero não, Claudinei. Depende,
tá? Mas não me parece um exagero não.
Tomar cuidado por causa que a pimenta
preta para quem tem gastrite irrita o
estômago. Tá com a pipirina que você
colocou aqui.
Eu uso na cozinha com pimenta preta,
óleo de coco, azeite de oliva. Funciona
sim. Tá vendo? Funciona. Preventivamente
funciona, né? Mas se você tivesse uma
artrite aí poderia não funcionar.
Boa noite. Boa noite.
Fala-se muito suplementos
antiinflamatórios, mas gostaria de saber
o que fazer para não inflamar o corpo.
Inflamação é uma defesa do organismo,
Marcelo, tá? Então, existe inflamação
boa, aguda, que é necessária. Por
exemplo, se você topar o pé numa pedra,
você quer que tenha inflamação para ter
cicatrização do seu pé. Agora, o que é
ruim é a inflamação crônica de baixo
grau descontrolada, tá? Então a gente
tem que controlar a inflamação, não
eliminar ela do organismo, tá? Então
para evitar a inflamação, tem uma vida o
mais saudável possível, mas só de você
fazer uma atividade física, por exemplo,
você pode inflamar o seu músculo um
pouco. Então a inflamação faz parte da
vida, não dá para evitar. O que dá para
evitar é inflamação de baixo grau
descontrolada,
tá? Já passei o o o santo aí, tá? André,
eu acho que você mandou uma mensagem
mais cedo, não tinha falado ainda.
Gostaria de falar que estou muito feliz
de estar participando desse grupo
também. Tô muito feliz que você esteja
participando. Maria Cláudia,
pode dar algumas sugestões das boas
curcuminas. Já dei, tá? Já dei.
Eh, mas posso voltar a falar disso.
Não sei se já foi falado, mas temos de
tomar a cucumina concentrada também.
Curou. Sim, já falei. Impressionante que
a médica gastroentologia me diz que a já
respondi isso aqui. Quais marcas com
confiável? Já falei, né? Porque o flex é
uma. E tem as outras que eu falei, a
cucumina longevida da Vitafora, a
Cuccumi Fitossome da Essential, a
Cuccumitec da Nutrilíbrio.
Eu nunca tomei de profenar. Que bom para
você. Like, like, like. Com certeza,
pessoal. Dá like nesse vídeo, hein?
ajuda aí o canal que tá sendo
prejudicado há muitos anos aí pela
plataforma,
porque tenho muita, mas muita mesmo
sonolência após o almoço. Gente, vamos
ficar no assunto de hoje, tá? Depois a
gente pode falar desses assuntos depois.
De nada, Maria de Lourdes, boa noite.
Como posso distinguir na hora de comprar
tecnologias que eu falei de absorção,
tá? Fitossomo,
lipossomo,
uso da pimenta preta. piperina, né?
Então tem que ver pela tecnologia de
absorção que eu comentei aqui no no
vídeo. Volta o vídeo, depois você vai
ver. Doutor, eu uso a cucuma para fazer
arroz. Isso diminui o poder? Não, não
diminui poder. Você vai est tomando com
alimento que vai ter uma potência muito
menor, mas é preventivo.
Fácil titura de assolhais. Legal.
Eh, a cúcoma das lojas de produtos
naturais não funciona. Depende, depende
da tecnologia. Rosana, como expliquei,
pode tomar concomina ininterruptamente?
Sim e não, tá? Eu tomaria sim, mas com
acompanhamento médico. Não tomaria eh de
forma ininterrupta sem acompanhamento.
É, deve ser a sua net, Givan. Ã, like,
like, like. Você também, Adriana.
Obrigado, viu, Terezinha? Obrigado pelo
comentário.
Indicação de cápsula de alho e orégano
que o senhor falou em outro vídeo.
Geralmente eu mando manipular nesses
casos aí, tá de cabeça agora. Não tô
lembrando de uma marca. Ó, esse aqui é o
link para compra que você tem um
desconto de 10% com o cupom que é esse
aqui, 10 off, tá? Vai ficar valendo até
amanhã de manhã. Você que tá
acompanhando a live aí vai ter esse
desconto.
Sim, tem que ser de confiança, sim. Tem
que ser de confiança, sim. O link tá
errado. Pera aí, deixa eu abrir aqui de
novo. Errado por quê? Deixa eu ver.
Não, esse link não tá errado não. Pera
aí. Vamos ver aqui.
Testar o link de novo aqui.
Ah, tá. É o link da imagem. Desculpa,
dei o link errado mesmo. Você tem razão.
Tá essa parte aqui que
Pera aí. Agora que eu entendi.
Me dá só um momento que eu vou dar o
nick certo. Obrigado ter avisado, viu?
Eu peguei o link da imagem em vez de
pegar o link do produto.
Deixa eu editar aqui. Mas não tem como
editar. Na verdade, eu vou ter que
colocar de novo o link aqui. Pronto,
agora o link tá certo. Obrigado por ter
avisado, viu?
Então, deixa eu colocar aqui um pouco na
tela esse link aqui, tá, pessoal?
Desculpe, eu coloquei o link da imagem
do produto em vez do
Nós vamos continuar aqui. Obrigado ter
avisado que o link tá errado.
E tem gente que falou que pegou
atrasado. Tem problema nenhum, gente. É
só voltar o vídeo. Dá, inclusive, dá
para voltar o vídeo com ele ao vivo, tá?
Vocês que estão assistindo ao vivo ao
vivo, basta você pegar ali o aquela
bolinha e você voltar que você vai ver o
vídeo em tempo real, né, no passado, tá?
Ã,
estou com Sinovit nos dois joelhos
quando devo tomar. Aliás, deixa eu gerar
um Qcode com esse com esse link aqui,
pessoal. Me dá um minuto só aqui. Eu vou
gerar um QRcode. Vou colocar na tela.
Cadê? Cadê o gerador de QR code? BR. É
isso aqui. É isso aqui mesmo. Pronto.
Pronto.
Ã Pá.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo copiar aqui.
Vou mostrar para vocês aqui
o QR Code.
Deixa eu ampliar aqui. Pera aí. Deixa eu
fazer um negócio aqui.
Deixa eu fazer um negócio aqui.
Venho aqui.
Mudar aqui o a imagem.
Mudar aqui a imagem.
É esse aqui ou esse aqui? Acho que é
esse aqui.
É esse aqui. Ah, cadê o Qcode? Cadê o
Qcode
aqui, pessoal? Aí tá aí o QR code na
tela de vocês. Vocês não estão vendo?
Ah, não aparece não.
Ou aparece aqui? Pera aí.
Tá aparecendo para vocês? Deixa eu
colocar ao vivo aqui para mim.
Deixa eu ver se tá aparecendo para mim
aqui.
Não, não tá não. Não tá não.
Não tá aparecendo não. Eu vou colocar
aqui
no overlay aqui. Pera aí,
deixa eu pôr um overlay aqui.
Ah,
me dá só um instante aqui que eu vou
abrir esse
code aqui.
Pronto.
Deixa eu ver se vai dar certo isso aqui.
Pronto, tá aí esse QR code tá aparecendo
na tela aí. Beleza? É o mesmo QRcode do
link, tá bom? Quem quiser utilizar o
celular pode usar esse QR code aí.
[Música]
Continuar respondendo as perguntas.
Sérgio, obrigado. Realmente eu percebi
depois que o link tava errado, mas agora
tá certo, tá?
Tintura de açafrão é boa? É boa, mas não
é tão boa quanto você tomar cucumina com
tecnologia avançada de absorção. O
álcool ele vai aumentar um pouquinho a
absorção da cúrcuma, sim. Tá.
Tomo cúrcuma com camomila,
estou com sinovite nos dois joelhos.
Depende. Se for um produto de alta
absorção, você pode tomar 200 mg duas
vezes ao dia. Se for um produto de menos
absorção, 500 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Ah, que mais?
Ã,
mesmo com artritatoide, meu exame de
PCE, resultado normal. Observação. Não
estou sendo medicada porque parei por
conta própria. Me médios para artrite.
Eu não sei se eu perdi alguma pergunta
sua aqui, mas parece uma continuidade de
alguma coisa aqui. A safrão ralado com
pimento do reino faz bem ajuda na
absorção. Que eu não falei, uma das
tecnologias que aumenta a absorção. Áo
hialurônico não é uma molécula muito
grande para ser absorvida?
Então seja acaba sendo absorvido sim,
talvez por liquig, tá? Eu te digo isso
porque tem estudos comprovando que o
ácido hialurônico vioral ele tem ação
melhorada da pele, tá? Tem ação de
envelhecimento. Inclusive eu tomo ácido
hialurônico para mim funciona.
Boa noite, doutor. Um grande abraço,
minha gratidão. Um abraço também. Ã,
o link tá aí, já coloquei na é esse o
link aqui, tá? E tem o Qcode aqui em
cima, tá, pessoal? Tem um QR code, caso
vocês queiram utilizar o celular.
T tã.
Quem tomou Astrazênica pode tomar por
quanto tempo? Se tiver acompanhamento
médico, pode tomar de maneira
indefinida, tá?
Ã, cupom de desconto. Esse aqui que eu
apresentei para vocês, ó. Aparece. Ah,
sumiu aqui. Tem que colocar de novo.
Pera aí. Esse o cupom de desconto, tá?
10% de desconto.
Não sei porque ele saiu da tela.
Então, de novo, ã, quem tem queda de
cabelo devido a sintoma pós spike deve
tomar por quanto tempo?
Patrícia, caso cada caso é um caso, tá?
Eu tomarei pelo menos se meses com
acompanhamento médico.
Boa noite, Dr. Alan.
A cucumina também é bom para as hernes
de disco? Sim, é bom para hern de disco,
é bom para dor de quadril.
Ó, o código de desconto está aí na tela,
tá? esse 10 off. OK.
Eu acho que tem um delayzinho, né, entre
o que eu falo e que vocês
o que vocês percebem, né?
Ah, cúp longa 95%.
Tem o mesmo princípio ativo da cúpula
flexível. O que que é cúpula flexível?
É com flex, quer dizer, né?
Não é o princípio ativo é o mesmo, a
tecnologia de absorção que é diferente,
tá? Vi,
de nada. Eu que agradeço, Patrícia. Bem,
pessoal, estamos atingindo uma hora de
live. De novo, o QR code está no canto
superior direito da sua tela.
O link eu coloquei, tá, nos comentários,
mas eu vou colocar o link também no
primeiro comentário do vídeo publicado.
Vocês têm aí um período de algumas horas
com esse desconto aí de 10%, é um
produto de alta qualidade que eu uso
para mim e para minha família. Eu
recomendo muito. Tem outras marcas que
vocês se quiserem ver as outras marcas,
eu falei de novo umas duas vezes durante
o vídeo, é só voltar o vídeo, tá? Então
eu agradeço muito a participação de
vocês, agradeço muito que vocês tenham
participado dessa live com perguntas
interessantes, inteligentes e a gente se
vê em uma outra ocasião, tá? Muito
obrigado aí pela gentileza de vocês, o
carinho e até a próxima. Um beijo no
coração. Até mais. O código de desconto
de novo, não sei se você não tá vendo,
tá aqui o código de desconto, ó. 10 off,
ó. 10 off. tá aqui no canto inferior
esquerdo, tá? Eu vou colocar também no
primeiro comentário agora com o vídeo
publicado, beleza?
Eu sempre dou o meu like, deve ser like,
né? Muito obrigado, viu? Muito obrigado.
Tá de novo, código de desconto tá no
canto inferior esquerdo, tá? Esse roxo
aqui, 10 off, QR code para compra, tá no
canto superior direito, tá? E o link
também eu vou colocar e fixado no
primeiro comentário, beleza, pessoal? Um
grande abraço, um beijo no coração de
vocês. Até a próxima. Ciao. Ciao.